dont bien sûr sénateurs vigiles in et
représentant les huiles aux goûts je
serai toujours à votre écoute j'ai géré
est toujours là pour servir de la merde
et face aux 50 amélie c'était sa
dernière en tant que président de saint
quentin en yvelines michel logis a tenu
à l'issue du conseil d'agglomération a
remercié ses collaborateurs mais aussi à
revenir sur ces trois années de mandat
ce soir oui c'était la dernière séance
ce comme on dit dans tout cas je voulais
remercier tous les élus qui se sont
impliqués et c'est vrai que les lutins
bleus si on n'a pas la même vision des
choses
on est très attachés à notre territoire
aidé à toujours fait ça dans l'intérêt
de nos villes dans l'intérêt de
l'intercommunalité et je pense que c'est
la grande leçon qu'il faut retenir
alors que les discussions se poursuivent
en coulisses pour désigner un candidat
pour lui succéder la date du 19 octobre
semble aujourd'hui confirmée pour la
tenue du scrutin
ce jour là l'ensemble des postes sera
redistribué lors d'une séance
extraordinaire sur le fond ce dernier
conseil du président logis aura surtout
été marquée par l'adoption à la
quasi-unanimité d'une motion de défense
de la ligne 18 les élus exigent que le
métro automatique soit réalisée d'ici
2024 pour soutenir le développement du
territoire
alors que des rumeurs insistantes
évoquent la suppression de la gare prévu
à guyancourt
par souci d'économie on peut pas avoir
des menaces comme ça alors qu'on s'est
battu depuis des années alors que tout a
été fait que le débat public a eu lieu
que tous les textes officiels sont
sortis quand on s'est engagé aussi dans
le cadre des jeux olympiques peut aussi
aller les chefs d'entreprise sont montés
au créneau pour expliquer la nécessité
si on n'a pas de ligne 18 y aura plus de
développement en termes de logement à
saint quentin en yvelines
il y aura plus de nouvelles entreprises
qui vont vouloir venir et peut-être même
que certaines vont décider de nous
quitter dans les prochaines semaines des
actions de terrain sont également
envisagés pour maintenir la pression sur
le gouvernement ait des différentes
délibérations retiendra l'attribution
d'un fonds de concours aux communes qui
pour maurepas et l'on courait coignières
est synonyme de feu vert à la
reconstruction d'un nouveau centre
aquatique
enfin les tarifs de la future vélo
station de la gare de saint-quentin ont
été adoptés ce nouveau service de
location sera facture
de 3 à 15 euros par jour 150 vélos
classiques 10 vélos à assistance
électrique et 10 vélos pliants seront
proposés la mise en service pourrait se
faire en octobre